so we had someone do a response video to
a video we made about them
you may remember king of wreaths he was
basically saying that you have it you
don't have to disclose it it is not my
job to disclose my HIV status to anybody
even partners it is both people job to
talk about theirs for health so ok I
chew on hero's response why I wanted to
and then I heard it and then I was like
maybe not but let's uh let's hear the
response the king orry's is very much
here and very much to deal with right
off the bat you gonna educate me by
misgendering me okay we're not playing
wow what better way to fight stigma Wow
okay there miss preaching things people
sometimes they want to be inclusive and
they just weaponize the exclusivity like
I would not think of ever doing that I
would never think you clearly present as
a male you present as a man I would
never think of misgendering you to try
to get at you that's so petty and
especially that's when I threw a fight
especially when that's your fight I want
you guys to just go back and forth
between both of the videos clearly watch
ours and see we never insulted him
personally even though you know we could
we don't do it because we want to still
stay on topic but
I have respect that you decided to go
that road I'm not mad at low blows are
fine keep going up low blows are fine
yes miss preach no way you won't take
that as an invitation girl we can get to
them you know justifying you out here
being xenophobic I saw them addressing a
video that I did on Twitter because it
seemed quite alien form and they don't
know what they talking about but we have
a lot of people who shout out anti-flag
ignorant statements to get attention on
YouTube nabeel's we will be addressing
that and even me okay whoever the hell
ms pretty children here okay there miss
preach whatever whatever okay I don't
think there's anything anti-black in
what we said I don't understand people
who feel attacked they feel it's then
tied down that's something that I've
noticed a lot of videos that we do if we
show some toxic traits of women
therefore people are gonna say that were
anti women yeah if we show some traits
about the trans community that is not
that makes no sense
we're transphobic but that's not even
the community is some people because you
know we have to acknowledge the fact
that they're not a monolith so I cannot
even go with saying it as a community
but when some people do some toxic
traits or say some things that are not
right we are against the whole thing and
that's not the fact we do that it would
be like coming after someone because
they work in business and we criticize
their business ethics and they're like
but I'm a woman and you can't say that
is woman like no no I talked about we
didn't talk about blame I don't know why
you said it was anti black but anyways
you know what let's fine
carry on we'll keep watching even though
telling me then what
- what tell me what I need to about get
pissed off tell me what I need to do as
a person living with HIV advocating for
the people living with HIV for the last
six or seven years before I even came
out as positive before even found I was
positive I was out here doing his work
at doing the research are you dumb are
you dumb
how dare you open your mouth to cheer me
with people when living with HIV need to
do because it's affecting other people's
life that's why we dare to do that
you're putting people that are not
living with HIV at risk that's what
you're spreading that we're telling you
that someone at is not hiv-positive
would like to know if you are engaging
with you that's pretty much it I know
anyway speak up no better safe
you were sitting for the Miss dirty
clause in their dirty room and talk in
front of a old outdated camera and react
to videos that is your legacy and watch
my room see you could have said
something you could have you could have
been like hey we're gonna debunk
everything that they said point by point
I was waiting for that no you're gonna
diss the camera you're gonna visit
microphone you're gonna diss the room
you're gonna this you're not gonna just
nothing you think you dealt with stigma
but you're not addressing the stigma
that you're dealing with you had a good
chance to say something but no you're
all up in your feelings which I
understand I get that a hurts ooh boo
boo is you hurt it went through your art
I get that understandable or I'm gonna
go and talk to them and that's not our
response that's just you being emotional
you gonna insult him you're gonna insult
me you're gonna insult us you
the room fine go ahead oh and you're not
gonna get no subscribers because not me
that doesn't say anything about what the
topic is stay on topic
what are we talking about here you had a
good chance to do it but she didn't do
it I was disappointed because I was
ready to listen to hear what you have to
say
let me hear a perspective of someone
that has HIV lanier you what's up what
you got to say I was actually ready to
listen but she came with your nonsense
oh your room dirty missing misses and
this is that and then and then and then
man and you're in front of that dirty
ass look you're doing a disservice to
your people I'm just confused
this man talked about our camera bro let
me see the quality of your lens broke
you talked about my room broke in front
of a white room there's nothing behind
you you're talking you're talking about
a subscriber count'
bro we got way more subscribers than you
and we've been on this platform less
time and I don't even want to be that
petty but it's just weird it's like
walking on the street and having a
homeless be a person being like hey man
you should take a nap you look tired I'm
like Cup you look homeless like why you
telling me anything when you in a dust
your position than me that's one two
don't do all this talking about how you
went on leave our video up so you can
use it as a teachable moment and then
you miss the opportunity to provide
people with that teachable moment I
didn't take him out of context I didn't
misrepresent him maybe he didn't elevate
his point properly right like either a
he meant what he said and it's dangerous
or be he didn't use the right words and
as someone who advocates for HIV people
he probably should use the right ones
when it's something that important right
because when you say something like oh
if you got it you don't have to disclose
it it's both people's responsibility to
have that conversation it's not my
response when you say stuff like that
it's almost as if your absolving
yourself of that responsibility it's
like no even if the other person is
irresponsible even if they're not smart
enough to ask those questions and
they're irresponsible you still have
that obligation to tell them that's our
stance I was waiting to hear
smart rebuttal from you that would prove
me otherwise but no you went straight to
oh my god miss Abba and preach right
starting with some petty misgendering
stuff these two idiots and then you
start to bring up your track record as
if that makes you infallible and makes
you never be wrong what does that have
to do with anything it's not because
you've been doing something for so long
that you've been doing it right look at
our politicians they've been in office
for 50 60 years do we think that they're
doing a good job and if we criticize
them with their rebuttal be you know how
long I've been where I don't care how
long you've been working in politics you
corrupt them off that's all that matters
so don't talk to me about your track
record because that wasn't broad
question we criticized you on one
specific idea and you didn't bring
anything to the table to raise the
discussion up instead you went to pity
which hey listen you might be king of
reeds but we King a penny okay we can go
there but we're not going to because
that's not what our channels about build
this up
talk about pity we think you're
propagating a terrible idea if we're
wrong tell us how that's it at the end
of the day we just want people to do
better that's all we want so those
disappointing very disappointing let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below do you think our stance is wrong
or do you think that his stance is right
maybe we miss something about the stigma
but overall I think our stance is pretty
clear we want to hear your thoughts
[Music]